By now, you should've gained everything
you need to know to understand the full
Kernighan-Lin Algorithm.
Recall the setup.
You're given a graph and
a partition of its vertices, v1 and v2.
You'll try to improve this partition by
swapping two subsets of the elements,
x1 and x2.
So how do you choose x1 and x2?
Here's the KL procedure.
First, compute the internal and
external costs for every vertex.
Next, mark all the nodes has unvisited.
Then, carry out an iterative procedure.
I'll fill this condition in momentarily.
Go through every pair
of unmarked vertices,
and pick the one with the largest gain.
Mark that pair as visited.
Now go through and update all the
internal and external costs as if a and
b had been swapped.
Note that you aren't
actually swapping a and
b, just updating the costs
as if you had done so.
Then repeat this procedure until
you visited all the vertices.
At this point, the algorithm has
computed a sequence of gains.
That is, this is the first
part of the algorithm, and
the output of the first part
is the sequence of gains.
Now, for the next part of the algorithm,
let's define something
called the cumulative gain.
That's Gain with a capital G.
A capital G Gain is the sum of all the
little gains up to a certain point, a j.
Kernighan's and
Lin's idea was to keep all the swaps
that maximized the cumulative gain.
If this cumulative gain is non-zero,
then you have a candidate x1 and
x2 subsets that actually
improve the partition.
You can then swap these two subsets and
update the overall cost.
Now for the last detail.
You'll repeat the entire procedure
we've just described, parts one and
part two, until there is no more gain.
In other words, if this condition is
false, then the algorithm terminates.
Oh, boy.
That was a lot of steps, but
hopefully the general idea is clear.
Now the main issue with
this algorithm is its cost.
Its sequential running time is
big O of v squared times d.
Where again,
d is the maximum degree of any vortex.
There are actually some more complex
variations of this algorithm that can
reduce the per iteration cost
to big O of the number of edges.
Anyway, for more of my notes
on analyzing the overall cost,
head to the Downloadables section.